my girlfriend's uh first date
uh this [ __ ] about to be cute yeah yeah
you take that deep breath it's gonna be
a picnic
we went to like the top of this like
mountain like like overlooked uh the
valley and stuff we were sitting there
were japanese or something uh no where
the [ __ ] was it somewhere in the
hollywood hills okay
and uh we're sitting on this bench we're
sitting there talking
and then she like puts her head on my
shoulder and i just put my
arm around her and i uh i kissed her on
her forehead
and she [ __ ] those laughs
she [ __ ] she brushed out laughing bro
you know how
my heart sank why because i was
embarrassed about
all that [ __ ] is
[Laughter]
[Applause]
she's like what am i your daughter
but where'd you go where did you guys
meet what uh
where would we be uh i think we went to
the store i think we better
you met the comic store yeah
you know like so that would be your
first date no that was your first time
uh there was another person with us oh
there's nothing you had
a home at a homie come here why'd you
invite
why'd you invite a homie in your first
kind of hype he was nervous
yeah dude what'd you say he was nervous
hmm this is first
she was like okay so then yeah you and
your buddy so yeah
and then you asked her out after that no
we just started kicking a little bit
more and then you know
it just like i don't know organically
happened and [ __ ] invited me
yeah when i kissed her on the forehead
bruh she [ __ ]
she was just like was it what an
impresso
was the one that wasn't one of them like
powder on the head
just squeezed her tighter too well you
you and your girl were like best friends
right chin so it's like we're already
close for over 20 years
damn and then a lot of her girlfriends
or her friends
i dated a few of her girlfriends so it
was saluted
and i remember thinking like she was
always like to me the most beautiful one
i've seen right yeah
and then look at the girls that i dated
love is tight lovely
i love his rocky too you know yeah i
love it sometimes every now and then let
it be
love's a windy room yeah it's a windy
road but then um
what was i gonna say oh oh my you
thought she was the cutest one
the beauty fashion was beautiful like
beautiful it was like the word and you
got been you guys weren't close to
because you would always
cool and my girlfriends at the time they
would always say like oh do you have
something going on with her i'm like no
no we're just we're just super close so
we ended up going you
[Applause]
because i knew it for so long it was
easy for me to take her to disneyland
for our first date
yeah that's stuck in hennessy too
disneyland at night
those when you get caught up to cheating
i promise i'm gonna do it again
that'll rub it you gotta rub it like
forehead is old school
but i feel you but you got to realize
this first one
you know cat have you been you've been
kissed on dates and stuff have you been
going on any date like
in covet it's [ __ ] it's i mean here
and there not a lot though i feel like i
just kind of hang out with people here's
my question have you had a forehead kiss
i love forehead kisses thank you so much
those are the sacred thoughts those are
sacred those winners like yo
you forever even you're falling enough
to be that cheesy you're a keeper
you're ballsy to be that's not cheesy i
think it's cheesy but it's cute forehead
kiss
yeah you hug your queen i do it all the
time you hug your queen kissing
you've been together for a while your
first kiss that's where it's kind of
like yeah that's why it's cheesy first
you like that guy oh yeah all right
stupid
it's a cute story too where did you go
uh malacanang
was there first yeah yeah yeah yeah you
just came to the show in phoenix yeah
she came to but our first official date
was my indoor picnic
you did an indoor picnic so you had
dinner at home shout out to kovan
yeah i had to that's what she's why did
you say picnic well because i moved the
furniture around and i got this
big ass blanket and i tried to do [ __ ]
like that yeah and i gave her a review
and yeah so i was dope i was romantic
but i didn't know it was six figures i'd
take that back
i can't really cook i try to make like
this cute dinner and it failed
and i was like yo let's just order
something and she like yeah she was cool
and
yeah and look where you all are shout
out to first dates
birthdays are [ __ ] weird yeah it's
always it's always i guess
it's like dinner you do dinner right the
dumbasses are the ones that do first
dates and go to a movie
that's stupid that's real stupid yeah no
so
what about a driving a nice restaurant
driving a little i mean you're in the
car the whole time that'd be better than
a movie
i should i took my ex on the drive-in
movie theater i know [ __ ] i knew she was
a [ __ ]
because for the first date i got to get
over my chest cause the first date would
we watch ted too we even get through the
middle of the movie she's already
getting me hit
oh okay man i don't know we could blur
that out but
i mean that's cool when i get off stage
at the lap factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just run a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together
on i'm just saying dude grab that mic
song